today
um on the 18th of august 2020
um i'd like to ask arafata
would you like to bless us today that'd
be great
foreign
um i know that everybody's here but is
there any apologies
[Applause]
anybody got any new jobs
voluntary time
um shall i take the minutes of
um from meeting held on the 16th of june
read
so i recommend that mahitahi joint
committee confirms
the minutes as a true and correct record
and
the circulated minutes of the meeting of
mahitahi jointly held on the 16th of
june
second by a blackie do i say your whole
name or what does that word
just say oh um all in favor
any abstain okay carrot
there you go just
just adrian just wanted me to remind
everyone that we're in live streams so
um this is being recorded so um
there may well be people no oh what the
hell i'm sure i think it's only
i think it's only voice recording isn't
adrian so you don't have to worry about
um visual appearance
[Laughter]
again if you want to but anyway this
livestream
thank you for that timely reminder
so uh first on the agenda we have the
reports and so we've got a report here
at
mahinakai area kaikou south from um in
flanigan
which is the landscape plan of
regeneration
and the recommendation that mahitahi
receives the report
thank you for your time this morning for
those of you whom i haven't met my name
is michelle flanagan
i work in the district regeneration team
and we work on implementing the land
uses
uh in the recovery plan of what was
previously red zone land
to date we've been largely working in
the kaiqua east regeneration area
building the new sports fields and
recreation reserve and now we're
starting to turn our attention to the
kaikoura south
area the purpose of this report is to
seek approval from the committee to
commence the planning and design of the
heritage in mahingakai area
including starting discussions on a
co-governance framework
i'll take the report as read if that's
acceptable and just pick up some of the
key points
um through that in the recovery plan an
eight hectare area was shown for
heritage and hingakai purposes
this area is shown on the map included
on page 19 of your agenda that's
attached right now
this area extends along the banks of the
kaikou river and the courtney stream
generally east of courtney drive
this land use was included in the
recovery plan as it was identified as
having significant cultural values
during the preparation of the recovery
plan
the heritage of mahingakaya area is
noted as being a public reserve
that provides space for cultural and
social activities and a unique
recreational experience for the
community
that was the definition that came
through the recovery plan
the development of the heritage of
mohingkai area seems a key partnership
between council and murunga and is a key
regeneration project we're continuing on
with
last year a preliminary report on the
area was presented to the kaikoi to a
hilly community board
the report was prepared by mr rupani and
mr wipo from environment canterbury and
was endorsed by the runanga
the report is included as attachment 2
to this report and that's on page 20
into the agenda the report focused on
the creation of an edible forest
consisting of two plant communities a
wetland community and a protocol forest
based on this report staff developed a
preliminary draft concept plan setting
out how these plant communities could
broadly looked on the site based on
environmental conditions
this preliminary job is on pages 30 to
33 of the report
the purpose of this preliminary draft
plan was to seek funding through the
provincial growth fund for fencing and
native planting
unfortunately the project didn't meet
the criteria for funding
but we're hoping that the plan may be a
good place to start discussions on how
the area could be developed
into an edible forest to build on the
preliminary draft concept plan and to
progress the heritage of mohingkai
report is seeking approval to establish
a working group to champion the planning
and design of this area this working
group could include members from both
the rinanga and from council and could
bring recommendations through this
committee
broadly speaking the group could propose
a co-governance framework
for the project recommend a name for the
reserve complete a concept and
management plan
prepare work and staging plans and
determine budget allocations
the proposed heritage of mangakai area
is a long-term partnership project
there is currently 60 thousand dollars
budgeted in the 2021 year for planning
and design purposes
an additional 1.68 million dollars over
22 to 26
for development of the area all subject
to long-term plan
processes this funding will not be
sufficient to develop the entire site
and therefore seeking additional funding
through third-party funding providers
will be required at later stages
development of the heritage of the kai
area is a key regeneration
and partnership project which we're
really keen to get underway
this report is hopefully the start of
this process i'm happy to answer any
questions
you don't
thank you my question michelle was where
is the proposed splash park going to be
in relation to this area here
that's on kaipai east regeneration area
so north of the river
does anyone have any further questions
to the report
just um thank you um
just on the 4.18 i wonder whether
[Applause]
yesterday about getting the portfolio
hold up
uh for regeneration and the list of
vendors in the working room
look at including that and some another
4.18
is that
the portfolio holder is out so just
it makes sense
passive observation which we had
yesterday with you know it's important
that we
you know one of the key objectives was
co-government's room
to lead this piece of work and i think i
think we still need to give some thought
about the best way of
ensuring the long-term co-governance of
this area and our best to achieve that
and the working group i think is a good
interim step to get some work
underway but i think as we think about
the co-governance
which at the moment the interim group is
a combination of
governance and staff working together
which will work well
but as we migrate to a co-governance
arrangement however that might look
that this working group might change in
the company's more
i'll pull it start oriented as opposed
to
what's essentially a mixed model that
sits here with some governors and some
staff working over it
while this will get us underway i think
we should review that once we actually
get to a point of
agreeing what the appropriate governance
watches are
which would come back to this community
to decide
[Applause]
thank you jim my idea around the
working group what does the commitment
look like
because i'm saying there's a person from
tuahu today
an elected member from mahitahi i'm like
okay
well that's more than a quiet area
but um that's what is the commitment
looking like on
something like a group like this before
it goes co-governance
to be fair the commitment hasn't been
detailed so we don't have a good idea of
what that would be i anticipate gym
seekers and books of staff and
governance there
those roles were fit so the staff i
would imagine would undertake the
majority of work in consultation and
collaboration
with the government's partners in that
but there would be requirements to meet
and work together and collaborate
yeah just like that tonight i think that
structures
does anyone have any further questions
on the show
michelle just under 4.18 and then
resolving it against the recommendations
so
you're going to bring it says if you'll
bring up a report
will you pick up that point if i made
around portfolio holder i just want to
be clear to other patents
we're happy to maintain to do this work
really okay it's the question i
have to leave that to the working group
i mean
i'm just look i've read through it quite
good and a lot of it's already done i'm
not sure
where my company would add values
and also given the small amount of
budgeting
i think you know someone like shane down
i think yeah i'm happy for the working
group
we're creating the working group
the governance issue is going to take up
a lot of time
so it's a working group uh
i think this working
michelle with whomever other support she
needs is
going to do the the driving with this
and you'll be
essentially bringing work periodically
to this working group
to review it so it's not a doing it's a
work
it is a governance function essentially
it's not a work
it's other than reviewing the work and
giving
a scene toward direction to michelle and
the team about what it is intended this
internal group is really getting us
under
getting this underway as opposed to a
um uh
a heavy time commitment so i think you
know
if you're if you're looking to
contribute here i'm anticipating maybe
an hour a month
might be a sort of expectation
until until that governance arrangement
has been
put in place which we probably took up
to six months depending on how quickly
the group
and i look at the purpose of the working
group to establish
the standard champion government
training design government
yet i thought that would be the role of
the government's group
and the support that the support staff
is that how that's being pitched so
you've got the working group aka
governance group
which is uh what i think has been said
maybe it's one hour a month with
uh staff support underneath that's cool
that's why i envisaged it to be
until such time as we've got a proper
governance group established
and then there will probably be a
marquee group
the governance group can ascent whenever
there is
a staff structure underneath the
concerts once it's established
are you about that
i just want to be clear on e
sorry um
i just want to be clear on the e and
this is for
uh are we clear to
what i heard earlier you're clear to
take away e
agenda
okay so you want me to remove e
okay so we receive uh oh
that mahitahi joint development
committee
recommends that council uh approves a b
c d f
in f okay
yes all of those
um second by al
getty uh all on favor
any against the eyes have it
excellent well done
you picking up this chair
[Laughter]
um
and then we're coming to britain because
we're going to talk about our
uh over the page um meeting
uh under item 10 anyway so if we just
note that
okay so i'd like to note that the next
meeting um of
mahitahi joint development committee is
scheduled for 9 30 tuesday the 20th of
october to be held in the function room
at any order town hall
this is this room by the way if we don't
know how to get in here
that was me earlier and
we're going to go into a briefing